so I uh went to Nintendo World couldn't
get a slot great so now we can get a
slot but I go like this dude I think
about my dad what would my dad have done
in this situation and the thing that I
had come up with in my head which is the
truth is my dad would have got into
Nintendo World no matter what
I know that about my dad
so in my head I'm like
my dad think he's better than me
I could do that
but it was a much different time back
then right in the 80s it was way easier
to sneak into places I mean you could do
anything in the 80s you could do
anything in the 80s you could walk down
the street with your dick all out and
punch everyone and not get caught
straight up ever and now it's like if
you even think about it they're like
this guy this guy's looking Shady get
him on camera oh [__] okay I'll just
I'll just be regular
no punching huh only thing I think I
want to go to the bathroom and all right
I know my dad would have got in but I'm
like but it's a different era but I
should be better than my dad at getting
into places and doing stuff that I want
to do for my kids because the students
are passes the teacher right that's what
we all hear the students got to surpass
the teacher right so I walk up they're
scanning and I go yeah I see they're
scanning we're [__] we're not [__]
we're not [__] right because we'll be
[__] when we can't get in and right
now it's before that so there's always a
plan that we can have
so I woke up and I said you know what oh
[__] my my wife has it on her phone and
I don't have the thing with me uh I
don't have it downloaded and she says oh
where's your wife and I said she's
actually a few back but she had the
stroller
um can we just like wait for her here
off to the side she says sure just wait
over there points behind her and I go
I don't have eyes
and I'm very slippery
so I said okay cool
I wait for a little bit I got Calvin
I wait for the lady to turn her head but
I wait a little bit longer I'm not the
guy who goes that first jump because she
could be faking us out she could be like
yeah wait right there anyway
but she didn't she goes hey wait yeah
all right boop boop boop three scans she
forgot about it you know why
I realized she doesn't give a [__]
right she just wanted us to make it easy
on her if we were going to sneak in she
was basically saying hey please
don't let me see it
so I grabbed Calvin I say let's go we go
into the [__] thing and dude we're in
I got my son Calvin in to Nintendo Land
by being sneaky in 2023 so hey my dad
could have done that in the 80s but how
about them apples my dad
[Music]
anyway
Crystal ear sneaks into [__] Nintendo
Land
um
we get in dude and it's first of all
it's too crowded
right
it's too hot
and it's too crowded
it's too loud
everybody there is ugly
crazy crazy crazy crazy crazy
congratulations
[Music]